coming very soon man polo g album coming
august fully produced by you fully i
want to see more artists do that [ __ ]
because like i feel like it's kind of
like a loss i don't i don't get they
don't choose me i kind of choose them
you know
so you're like yo polo let's do an album
if you don't say no i'll kill you see
look polo g is you can't do him like
that i'm just saying i know you're
threatening travis scott he's your
friend i don't know he's got a polo g
two different people apologies a little
against it feel me he just i told him he
grew like four inches since i met him
like he's getting bigger and bigger he's
a really nice kid too that's my brother
i love him to death he just
when i first met him i went to the
studio with him for like three times he
didn't say one word to me he's quiet
because i feel like he's kind of an
introvert
he is like nothing i'm talking about
like he came in with his artist story
shout out to story
he had just signed score he gave corey
is currently on tour with nle chapa i
believe so she might be out here
gave him some money took a picture with
score he didn't say a word to me they
did i was just like okay this [ __ ] is a
little crazy came back the next time
kind of did the same [ __ ]
then my boy busy called me and was like
yo i want you to come to the studio i'm
like bro i'm not pulling up on that
[ __ ] i'm like he don't talk bro he
don't say anything
so when i got there
this that this last time he he did he
did a record and he had put the record
out it's called young and dumb he did
the record he did that was the first
song we ever did ever since then it's
just been my little brother it was just
a wrap